art is a flower enjoy it now for
tomorrow another comes a saying from the
planet Caledon the Dune encyclopedia
before the start of doom Duke Leto and
the lady Jessica had spent the previous
two decades on the third planet in the
Delta Pavone a star system the planet
was called Caliban and it was the
birthplace of Paul Atreides though
Arrakis would later become his home
Paul's father Leto was also born on
Arrakis the Atreides held fiefdom over
the world and had lived there for 10,000
years more than 26 generations the great
house dominated all aspects of the
planet by air and sea and also
maintained an extremely loyal standing
army castle Caledon was the official
residence of the planets ruler the
structure was thousands of years old and
built of stone and wood it contains many
rooms and halls the castle stood
alongside a great river and many rooms
provided views of the Atreides orchards
and the mountain called sabi
the economy of Caledon flourished under
house Atreides the planet's natural
environment generated a large
agricultural industry Caledon is a wet
rainy world with many oceans rivers and
mountains the bountiful paradise planet
supported a diverse array of animal and
plant life on land and underwater
orchards many of which were owned by
House Atreides fed much of the planet's
economy fine wines and Pondy rice which
was a staple and a Calladine diet were
also major exports fishing was the
largest industry on Caledon it was
ingrained in the culture of the planets
people over the course of the six dune
novels Caledon would eventually become
known as simply dan all things
referencing Caledon referred to as
dannion the dune encyclopedia which is
viewed known canonically by some and
taken as gospel by others describes the
Society of Khalid an Khalid an was ruled
by six minor houses who divided up the
planets three continents with four
hundred combined provincial regions
under them this was until 86 77 AG when
polos the sixteenth Atreides was granted
the fiefdom by Emperor el Roode the
seventh the Encyclopedia states that
food was easily accessible from the
various seas and plants full of fruits
and berries the population of the planet
felt little need for formal training
most of the planet felt no need to work
at all children of the elite studied in
governance school which was found in the
capital city the study program was four
years long and dealt with statecraft
leadership tactics and civilian control
even this program was not a rigorous one
the problem that the students would face
on the Paradise world of Caledon would
not be great
Caledon relied heavily on family
teaching and what they called watching
and doing a child learned how to live
simply by taking part in day-to-day
family life children were taught to swim
before they learned to walk preparation
for survival in the water rich
environment of the planet was necessary
the entire population of Caledon
according to the Encyclopedia had easy
access to some sort of studio reading
room auditorium or theater many
productions in dance theater and music
were presented there was much interest
in sculpture composing film painting and
philosophy as well Paul Atreides was
born and lived the first 15 years of his
life on a planet that seems to be a
total opposite of the planet he would
later call his home whereas dune is a
barren harsh desert world Caledon is a
bountiful paradise whose people have
heightened opportunities for leisure
which could never exist on Arrakis
you